[Music]
do you guys know about gwyneth paltrow's
company goop goop oh yeah she made a
candle that smelled like a [ __ ] right
she made a candle that smells like her
[ __ ] smells like [ __ ] they sell they
sell vagina eggs that you can put up
there they sell vagina eggs
you shove them up your vagina you shove
them right on up there right
it's like it's a crystal it cleanses
your are you lying no that's a real
product they have these things called
yoni eggs bro and they they say they
harness the power of energy and you
[ __ ] shove it right on up in your
vagina and then you squeeze it out i
wish i was kidding i'm not kidding i
wish i sold crystals yo what a [ __ ]
market that is dude it enhances the
connection that you feel with your body
enhances the connection of that egg up
in your vagina so you know what does it
do is it helps them with their kegels
absolutely [ __ ] nothing oh oh that's
not true actually oh yeah it's a
nigerian accent it's not true yeah we
have a documentary series about a goop
it's [ __ ] real i looked it up it's
[ __ ] real
what up with the [ __ ] candles they
really have [ __ ] candy they have a
candle that smells like one of the
pouches [ __ ] that's what it says it
says this smells like my [ __ ] we're not
even kidding well it's her personal
personal vagina
notes of lavender and honey blossoms
and snake oil and scams
hey whoa dude her [ __ ] smells that good
i don't know she thinks it smells that
good because she wanted she made a whole
candle line off of it imagine being so
[ __ ] full of yourself that you made a
[ __ ] like body deodorant like
basically imagine being right like it
just smells glorious yeah imagine if
barbell did a bunch of r d to get like a
perfume it's not like your [ __ ] ball
sack dude
imagine bart thinks he's so tight that
everyone needs to smell his balls and
then people actually [ __ ] buy it oh
and the brand's called shmegma smegma
but like spelled all french like
with the accent on it with two dots over
the a
so yeah you step two you gently shove it
up your vagina like you would a tampon
the slighter the slightly larger side of
the egg first work your pelvic floor
while you're shoving it up there and
feel the connection to your body by
squeezing and releasing the egg you
might begin with a 10 to 15 minute
session if comfortable build up a
practice if it brings joy i need to see
an example of this for science purposes
does it say like the dimensions of how
big the egg are just says it's it's it's
1.57 inches in length
and 1.18 inches in width for you to
shove it up there i feel like if you
shove it up in there you might get lost
well you're not a woman so how would you
not i think there's a i think there was
a lawsuit actually with one of her
products or whatever that had to do with
a vagina that got stuck or whatever dude
i hear things get stuck in vaginas
constantly yeah this is what i hear
it's my ear on the streets there are a
series of lawsuits involving
there was a man who bought um this
smells like my [ __ ] i'm not kidding he
actually did buy this and he left the
candle burning
like like by his nightstand and the
whole [ __ ] thing caught on fire oh
nice wait was that it was that was that
a problem with the candle or was that a
problem with him just leaving things
burning for too long it was a problem
with her flammable [ __ ] that's what it
was yeah yeah
no this is fire
no so the problem is that it exploded oh
that's a problem what exploded blew up
blew up dude so he yeah he's he's that
push is too ranked that's a guy from
texas which is just hilarious to me a
guy from texas bought the busy candle
and let it burn between the costumes
guys
that's what it is yeah
so he says it exploded on his bedside
table when he left it burning
and it engulfed in high flames and left
a black burn ring on his
nightstand and then but gwenopaltro's
like yeah but we say on the candle not
to burn it for more than two hours at a
time oh
sucks
slam dunk
did your candle be [ __ ] imploding
like that well you shouldn't burn it for
more than two hours have you ever burned
a candle for longer than two hours yeah
it never explodes and never exploded but
it didn't also smell like a vagina so
you got to be true thoughtful about that
this is a 75 vagina smelly candle is
that how much it is it's premium 75 [ __ ]
dude for 75 dollars jesus it better be a
fleshlight am i right
hell yeah bro quarter cam corner tab
are you sure it wasn't the candle next
to the curtains
oh the candle next to his bomb stash and
his
are you sure it wasn't the gun powder
yeah he's texan after all his convenient
gasoline stash
[Laughter]
so some there's there's been another
incident involving goop oh boy um there
were two guys they're all guys why are
they all guys attending you don't smell
their [ __ ] that's why
attending an event at gwyneth paltrow's
group store in the hamptons
um so these two guys are there and she
has a store she has a store yeah what
yeah they're in new york how do you know
so much about google i've watched a lot
of documentaries on google because i i
hate watching it they have documentaries
dude this guy wears so many american
flags and he [ __ ] goes to goop
he's at the store like but i [ __ ]
hate this [ __ ]
this is not even [ __ ] like the ladies
like the ladies like like scanning and
[ __ ] he's like oh i'm just hate buying
just
the ladies [ __ ] it's like oh you're a
regular i have the rewards points and
everything
because every time steve says something
he has so much info and i'm like oh my
god how do you [ __ ] know so much
that's a good idea is this the same
business that did the [ __ ] glitter [ __ ]
yeah wait what was that
okay there's [ __ ] glitter they did all
of that billion dollar company right the
glamping or whatever the [ __ ] it is
no because every [ __ ] year there's
like a weird hollywood celebrity company
that comes out with some weird [ __ ] a
lot of it is it the same one it's like
[ __ ] jewels a lot of it is just goop
yeah a lot of it is what is [ __ ]
glitter and [ __ ] jewels
what's that what do i have questions it
enhances your [ __ ] body's connection
with your natural order bro
ah i'm in i could use some of this stuff
i want some penis jules george clooney
needs to come out here yeah yeah if
george clooney came out i'm [ __ ]
signing up to that email list today
every time or matthew connaissance bro
matthew mcconnell i'm a stroke right now
no remember when matthew mccoy that's
how binding pronounces it remember when
he was in like reign of fire like a
bunch of shitty rom-coms yeah but then
he was like on true detective yeah
interstellar true detective was like wow
and it's like he had the mcconausons
dude he's like
he started doing lincoln commercials
yeah dude he's a tight guy he's a tight
dude i was like lincoln's pretty cool
car man i like wild turkey now cocaine
and hookers my friend cocaine and
hookers when did when did goop get
created uh ryan i don't know man
early early you watch the documentary
what are the coordinates to every goop
store
don't have one on a on a list at home in
a manifesto you have to say
for internet purposes that was a joke
nice nice well handled um so
these two guys are at a group store
and all of a sudden
they
they're using this kind of lotion that
they have this door and they got set on
fire
it just combusted it's spontaneously
combusted
sensing a theme someone added alcohol to
a sternocan
which caused it to flash what's a
sternocan uh i don't [ __ ] know just
i thought you would know i don't know
i had to ignite it somehow i think they
[ __ ] went like this and then probably
went like this and then went
yeah
yeah from all the indoor smoking that
we're doing in the 2022. i think a
strong hand is those things that you you
can light up you know and like i'm gonna
google it because it's gonna bug me i
start okay yeah i'm a googler too
who's gonna get it first
yeah me yes it is that [ __ ] it's a it's
a little can it's like a little burner
thing let me see it's a little burner
thing
it's like you know like the hot plates
or whatever like food yeah yeah
banquets but some dumbass who works at
goop is like let's add alcohol to that
and so it set these two cats on fire who
were next to it i mean but why would
they put that in a loan everyone getting
caught on fire there's alcohol in hand
sanitizer yeah yeah so that's what's
going on goop is a [ __ ] show that's
what's going on who doesn't get it wait
so when you watch these goop
documentaries right yeah they don't talk
about this [ __ ] they're pretty what was
it like
expose on [ __ ] like well a lot of
theirs was so scary one of them one of
them was on there because they have a
netflix like docu series or whatever
where gwyneth paltrow has like these
like scared employees that are going and
doing like life-changing stuff they did
one with wim hof
she like pushes her like employees into
the freezing water or whatever they're
like it's so refreshing
and you can tell like a lot of them
don't want to be there yeah stuff like
that so it's like a shitty company like
exposing the yeah but i mean when you
the documentary is trying to paint them
it's like wow revolutionary it's gonna
foul
so i'm going to read a statement now
from goop who says that the claims about
the exploding candle have no merit but i
need you guys to understand why i'm
reading it like this it's because
the so so here we go we're confident
we're confident this claim is frivolous
in an attempt to secure an outsized
payment from that press heavy product
we stand behind the brands we carry
sorry i just shoved this this [ __ ]
thing up
shoving it up there and you gotta hold
it on to it
and the safety of the products we sell
we stand by
here heretic the brand that surprised
the candle oh god it fell out a lot
has substantiated the products
performance and safety through the
industry standard to testing wow and
then they picked they reached down and
the whole crystal [ __ ] right now is so
cracking like you could make a [ __ ] ton
out of it tell me we gotta start selling
some [ __ ] crystals bro i have a
friend that buys way too many crystals
like way too many crystals i'm like
jesus christ for your friend what's the
draw like what's she just likes them i
guess i i don't know i think that they i
think it's like having like a collection
well they're supposed to like do energy
[ __ ] or some [ __ ] right
that's better than the [ __ ] pet rock
phenomenon that happened
i'm more on board with the pet rock it's
have you ever seen crystals with led
lights behind them that's pretty cool
i'm okay with that i like the glass bone
mushrooms that have that oh i like that
too i got this new product right here
you could stick it up your [ __ ] it's
gonna help boost your success it's gonna
help you [ __ ] be rich as hell it's so
we can tell when joe's coming when
you're walking around you already have a
rattle all day though
it's like a rattlesnake they hear you
coming dude yeah you're gonna be [ __ ]
rich as hell it's gonna hear your food's
coming with an easy price of 4.99 not
four dollars 499. yeah because if you
want all that fortune you know you got
to pay up and look it balances by itself
if only we were shoving those up our
[ __ ] why luna wouldn't have gone
down i know right
fix inflation am i right